.
TWO OTHER DEAD MEN WERE
DISCOVERED WITH GUNSHOT WOUNDS.
THERE WERE NO U.S. CASUALTIES IN
IRAQ.
AT LEAST 3 ROCKETS LANDED ON THE
AIR BASE.
THERE HAS BEEN NO CLAIM OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE U.S. ACCUSED MILITIA GROUPS
OF LAUNCHING SIMILAR ATTACKS.
THE PENTAGON SAID THE U.S.
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN WILL
BE COMPLETE LATE NEXT MONTH.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS BE
CRITICIZED FOR WHAT WILL HAPPEN
AFTER THE GROPES ARE GONE.
-- TROOPS ARE GONE.
JENNIFER.
>> HE DESCRIBED WHAT HAPPENED.
>> IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> THE U.S. JUST SENT $4 MILLION
TO CREATE A CUSTOMS CROSSING
POINT.
THE TALIBAN HAVE A SOURCE OF
REVENUE.
>> THE LOSS OF TERRAIN HAS TO BE
CONCERNING.
HOPE AND MORALE MATTERS.
AS YOU WATCH THE TALIBAN MOVING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WHAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN IS IN
THE PEOPLE LOSE HOPE.
>> PEOPLE WHO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
EVERY DAY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
LINE UP IN EMBASSIES TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN SOONER.
>> THE PENTAGON IS NEGOTIATING
WITH A COUNTRY TO SERVE AS
A DRONE BASE NOW THAT THE U.S.
DOESN'T HAVE THE USE OF BAGRAM
AIRLIFTED NORTH OF KABUL.
>> WE HANDED BAGRAM AFFAIR BASE
OVER TO THE AFGHANS.
IT'S AN ASSET TO PROTECT US FROM
TERRORISTS.
IT COUNTERS RUSSIA, CHINA AND
IRAN.
>> WE ARE GOING DARK IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WILL BE
LONG-TERM CONSEQUENCES.
>> IN TERMS OF THE THOUSANDS OF
AFGHAN TRANSLATORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO FACED DEATH THREATS
FOR WORKING WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, CONGRESSMAN MCCALL
SAID THEY ARE NEGOTIATING TO
SERVE AS A